this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah let's kick it off welcome everyone
uh this is season four of the Cornell
Turf Show something that started uh
really out of necessity during the
coveted pandemic when uh you know Frank
and I were looking for things to do
looking for people to see and at in any
capacity even the virtual world uh now
we're on season four and thanks to
everyone who's been listening and
enjoying the information along the way
uh Frank and I have really appreciated
doing this uh we get to talk to a lot of
great people we have guests on every
week we get to learn a lot of things Our
Guest this week is Dr Arthur digaitano
director of the Northeast Regional
climate Center uh so we're going to get
to a conversation with our a little bit
later but I'm going to bring in my
co-host as always Dr Frank Rossi Frank
welcome back to season four good to see
you all and uh just I'll second that
Carl
um this is really great because of the
people we get to share it with right and
now you got uh three Italian Guys so
with without for any further Ado without
any further to do let me get to it so as
Carl said we started this just howling
at the moon Carl and I I think uh during
the pandemic just to try to support uh
guys who didn't know if you could work
uh how could you work how many people
could work how many people in a truck
all the things that were involved in
getting things done
um and now it's really created a body of
content that someday somebody's going to
mine and they're going to say wow that
Rossi was stupid but scamenty man he
really had it going on so I like to pick
pictures I still do it we're very
fortunate that we share these things
collectively and for those of you listen
on the podcast I've got a slide that
basically shows uh uh people laying sod
around a bunker and a blizzard and I
think this is what caught us off guard a
little bit but really in in in honor of
having a uh a wannabe meteorologist with
us I thought that this particular uh
tweet was was really typified something
we've been talking about art for a
really long time and that is the damn
win so so I appreciated the way this
meteorologist uh presented this and for
those who don't know art is involved uh
here in the earth and Atmospheric
science department uh and has personally
trained a lot of people maybe even this
particular woman I I was thinking those
are bullets directly from my class on
the on the digatano wind speed scale
that's awesome
so great she could be a student and she
doesn't cite you but listen before we
get going with art and growing grass uh
I want to bring in my co-host Carl bring
you back and and also say what a joy
it's been working with you and
especially in your new role as the urban
environmental scientist right we're in
the process of uh hiring a new person
for the state park Agronomy job uh and
Golf Course ecosystem job and Carl
you've assumed this new role and we're
going to give you a chance to rant uh
potentially about one of the topics I've
been listening to you rant about for a
little while and the golf ball is
changing so Carl without any further Ado
it's all yours brother yeah thanks Frank
we're getting into some of these
segments now as we progress in some of
these Seasons I'm definitely going to
get to some of the things I'm interested
in my new job capacity ecosystem
Services the uh the value of turfrass
and urban Landscapes uh but but the
topical discussion for our golf show
this week really stems from uh the
recent announcement announcement from
the USGA RNA about a new golf ball so
they announced really their intent to
create this model local rule basically
they want to have a golf ball for only
Elite competitions we don't really know
what Elite competitions mean yet that's
going to go shorter somewhere between 15
and 20 yards shorter uh there's a lot of
Hammond and Han about if it's good for
the game bad for the game
and I really looked at the two arguments
that USG and RNA have made to
um sort of reason why this is something
they should do and the first argument
really has to do with uh the skill sets
of golfers Now versus back in the day
and how that shifted because of the
equipment and is that good or bad I
don't want to get into that today but
that's sort of their primary argument
the secondary argument is what I do want
to talk about today they say in in their
statement they said increased hitting
distances and course lengthening
threatens golf's long-term
sustainability Frank that's that's a
pretty uh interesting statement uh well
they've got in our lane Carl okay
and we've studied this so this is what I
want to get into the idea of
sustainability for most golf courses out
there the only version of sustainability
is is financial economic sustainability
are you making money and able to thrive
but again we got to go back to this is
competitive Elite competitions right so
when they talk about courses who are
affected by the new golf ball having to
change their Golf Course mayor Marion St
Andrews Augusta National Cypress Point I
got a picture up here for for those
watching of a new t-box Augusta just
made the 13th hole they made a new two
bucks there about 40 yards they added
they paid 30 million dollars for that 40
yards of course length that doesn't
sound to me Frank like of course that's
struggling financially already well I
wish I had that 40 yards of land I got
50. that much oh you're paying almost a
million dollars per yard to lengthen
that rule so economically that's that's
not what they're looking for here
they're talking about environmental
sustainability their argument is that
because courses have to lengthen they
then have to maintain more golf course
and that requires more resources more
inputs pesticides fertilizer water
greenhouse gases right we've studied
this Frank we've got two papers out now
looking at pesticide used and pesticide
risk on golf courses now we've looked at
it sort of internationally not even just
in the U.S and what our researchers
showed in all these cases is that the
Fairway resource use the pesticides we
apply to Fairway the same is true for
fertilizers irrigation the greenhouse
gases we spent Mowing and applying
cultural practices to these areas the
fairways are the primary driver of
resource Utah golf courses because
they're very big right we may not treat
them quite as intensely as the greens
but they make up such a larger area 25
30 35 acres and especially on
Championship courses which have high
expectations
so it'd be interesting for us to know
how have courses changed sort of how
they lay their course out have they
increased their Fairway acreage over the
years it turns out this has been studied
and it's been studied by the USGA and
the USGA green section did this a couple
years ago they mapped courses over time
using aerial images and GIS software uh
and and they used 80 random courses they
even had Championship courses in there
and they're finding was that
Championship courses had actually
decreased their Fairway acreage by six
acres from their Inception despite
adding 300 yards of length uh that's
actually the opposite of maybe what we
thought right they were saying one of
the usga's arguments in the statement
hey we're managing more land that's
unsustainable from this data we're
actually managing less of that land of
that Fairway land uh which is the most
resource use intensive as we know from
our work so if you get to my verdict
here is the golf ball affecting
sustainability of Championship nurses
I'm giving that a thumbs down Frank
that's not that's not what's affecting
the sustainability what I will say is
affecting the sustainability are these
other factors the player expectations
right green speeds this comes back too
and when you look at courses TPC
Sawgrass looked beautiful last week
played beautiful and it's super uniform
right and that requires a lot of
resources to maintain uniformity across
200 plus acres that's what the players
demand they they want every Fairway
every Green every bunker right all the
rough to react the same way across a a
changing landscape that's very resource
use intensive and when it doesn't happen
like Chambers Bay you can see a couple
tweets here of Pros uh getting up in
arms about that so if we're thinking
about environmental sustainability Frank
there's a lot of other factors I would
address well it's interesting Carl that
you know I love this and this is a wow
right this is a bit of a wow because
intuitively you think well if it's
longer it's got to be more land right
because length is going to give you land
and it's so fascinating that they by
their own measure they're not indicating
uh that that's the case but it is
rendering some of these Elite golf
courses irrelevant to the thing you
didn't answer the question there brother
I'm not letting you go should there be
two different types of balls
that that's a different question what I
wanted to answer was was why are they
doing this and I I'm not going to buy
the sustainability argument good if you
want to say hey we want to go to Cypress
Point and we want to stay at Pebble and
we don't want to change St Andrews
that's much more of sort of a uh you
know touchy feely conversation yeah yeah
that uh you know I I could either take
it or leave it I really don't care okay
so no verdict on bifurcation
uh it's I I don't buy the arguments
they're making there you go all right so
listen let's talk about Golf and a lot
more people are playing uh now that Jim
copenhaver and his pellucid group is
involved with National Golf Foundation
they got really good round numbers round
numbers are up dramatically from when we
started this show and we're holding on
to a lot of people that came back to the
game so for number one the thing to say
is at the end of 22 we had about 40
million more rounds about 12 percent
more rounds 13 more rounds uh in in 2022
than we did when we started the pandemic
what's fascinating is the weather sucks
art
the weather sucks right so look at this
data from from golf playable hours from
pellucid over a a long period of time
now golf playable hours as you got
enough light and Jim's uh Secret Sauce
says the weather factors are good for
golf right that you'll go out and play
golf so places like San Diego are pretty
much only well not this year but pretty
much only governed by how long the day
is because it's 70 and sunny every day
in San Diego for the most part so
obviously you'd imagine a high volume of
playable hours there and at the other
end a very low volume of playable hours
even here in central New York where we
thought we'd be playing already when you
look at the long the 10-year average we
have less time uh people for to play
golf and look at 2022 nationally it was
a big drop 10 12 percent more people
playing on less time to play so here's
another way that uh pelucid looks at it
this is playable hours year over year
here so compared to 20 uh one 22 had 20
percent less playable hours in the month
of November
but look at the utilization way off the
charts seven percent up year over year
more golfers with less time are really
leading to concentrating traffic and
Carl has really pioneered a lot of
discussion on how we should be thinking
about traffic uh in the golf business
moving forward and using this pellucid
data to demonstrate to people hey this
is not only we got more people they're
playing in a compressed amount of time
in certain places now Art here's the
picture
is that from the school of the mines the
one on the left I think that's right
when I first got here on the left oh my
gosh so we've got here about the same
time art and I are in the same tenure
class not oddly enough so we share that
we met that President Jeff Lehman who
was here for five minutes that's
probably how we got this that's probably
how you and I got tenured the guy can't
believe he tenured us and then he left
he left holy crap and I have been at
this a while and you know we started
just doing conference calls and it led
to being able to use weather and climate
data to try to help turf grass managers
grow grass and we've been doing this a
long time I don't think people even paid
attention to it when we first started
doing it but it allowed us to begin to
collect data and look at Trends and we
published a paper in 07 basically
foretelling what we're experiencing
right now is that exactly we have more
consistent dollar spot pressure or and
been a big shift in many areas to the
fall as a heavier heavy period of time
so this was really appreciate at the
time to do it now here's I'm going to
try to set you up as best I can I got
winter with a question mark because it
looks like it just got here and it's
hopefully not going to stay very long
looking back at the December to February
time period right I love these ranking
systems you look at the northeast or
everything that's orange all right this
has got to be like top five ten percent
of the warmest Winters we've ever yeah
go ahead yeah I mean you do the math
there right that period of record starts
in 1895 so if you do the math those are
pretty much you know top one top two
actually in in in most cases okay so
then I was a little surprised by this
um because I was hearing about not as
much snow not as much rain but we here
in central New York you could you know
in central New York here oh sorry
there we go let me get the pen and of
course for those people uh listening on
the podcast you can't see it but I'm
circling the central New York where it
looks almost 200 percent above normal
but I go on Long Island where Beth Page
is and they tell me it's pretty dry down
there so it's on whole what would you
say about the moisture from the winter
yeah I think the the moisture from the
winter helped us out a lot if you can
remember back in the fall um you know
most places a lot of places in New York
and New England especially in
Massachusetts we're really talking about
drought there was a lot of drought uh as
we moved into the fall so really uh this
map and if you look at any of the
drought Maps really show that uh the the
winter pretty much took care of that
drought
um so we had adequate adequate or if not
above normal rainfall for most places
but not all places yeah that's true I
mean again New York and or Northern New
York and New England really good
rainfall Stream flow has jumped up
groundwater has jumped up so
everything's looking really optimistic
there but uh like you kind of point out
as you move further south things don't
look all that that good and you know on
this map even the further south you go
uh the worse it gets so there is still
some lingering dryness uh not quite
drought but but boy right on the
borderline there in Long Island and and
as you move into the New Jersey and
Philly area
temperatures been the story and it looks
like um eight to ten days we're going to
stall again you know we got this teaser
at the end of February this is off of
your uh drought page and it also looks
like we're going to be at least slightly
on the dry side for a lot of the
Northeast but it looks hard to predict I
know how you feel about anything more
than 48 hours what do you want to say
about predictions for the next 8-14 I
mean as I mean if you went through that
time series of my pictures uh my faith
in the 8 to 14 day forecast has has
really expanded a lot and you know I I
actually do put a lot more faith in
these uh in time and you know I think
what you're showing the next week here I
think this is going to be short-lived um
I mean we're gonna you know we're gonna
have a bit of a cool down
um you know today at least up here in
Ithaca it's supposed to almost crack 50
but then drop down a bit uh as we move
into the weekend and things like that so
I think this one week period here that
you're showing is is you know kind of a
I think you you said it well a pause
basically like a stall yeah the other
thing just looking at it I know the
forecast temperatures again for Upstate
in our area next week or or probably mid
40s and that sounds pretty good actually
so um but we're getting into that time
of year where yes it's below normal but
uh uh below normal is still uh you know
uh getting to be not too bad I guess
well and to your point thank you for
giving me a perfect transition
I stumbled across this data you know how
art we always talk about the length of
the growing season and how things have
changed over time and how climate change
is bringing the climates of New York
City the metro area maybe closer to the
Philly area on its way to the Baltimore
area right and we're seeing that with
warm season grasses slowly starting to
creep up and and frost-free days are an
indication of that so here's some data
from growing season link just looking at
that and you see a real shift in the
slope here art and it's the first time
I've ever seen people put actual days on
it you're looking at it skeptically you
know the 80 to 2000 period 12 days per
decade does that mean we've added almost
a month in 30 in in in 40 Years of our
growth month yeah right 10 years a
decade so yeah almost almost a month
um I mean again
um you can take this graph in a number
of different ways ways I'd argue in a
lot of cases that 80 to
um you know to current period of time is
a bit of cherry picking because there is
a number of years there in the 80s and
uh what I really think is more dramatic
about this graph is you know when you go
to the 50s to the present right that's a
nice long period of time and you have a
nice consistent Trend there so I mean
you can play games with where you're
going to start things and you'll get get
a consistent Trend but yet that can
Trend that trend is consistently going
up well and boy aren't you the perfect
guest because the topic for today are is
Trends and you know we've Advanced some
of our understanding of Growing Degree
Days in in many ways our use of them uh
base 50 base 32 but this was a year
where we really called into question
whether our March 15 start date that we
always used historically and honestly it
really comes as an artifact from the one
the weed control model that was for 24d
uh we don't use that date I think for
base 32 but maybe we do I don't know I
know our our models weren't up so here's
the question for today or I mean I'm
looking at I pulled this uh yesterday
this is the proxy seed head thing from
uh Michigan State and it's basically
saying that you know the Metropolitan
New York area Southeastern New England
all the way into central Pennsylvania
should be making their seed head
application so first off how do I want
to make a little more sense of Growing
Degree Days it's a goofy question when
is a growing degree day not a growing
degree day but my point is about the
stall
right we let's say we counted them since
January and we had them that said we had
50 or whatever we had right for the last
month it's been sitting there
does that mean we start at zero or did
we get to capitalize on the 50. and this
is the question because we base
especially in the springtime a lot of
our models on this Growing Degree day
thing so I want to give you a chance to
sort of give us a you know a 101 if I
was sitting in your class on Growing
Degree Days and talk about some of the
sort of General issues we have and
things we still need to learn before we
can use these things discreetly right I
mean I think I'd start out with you know
a growing degree day has sort of you
know it they've been around for a long
time right and they're actually a pretty
simplistic measurement of really just uh
saying how far is the average
temperature of a day
um basically different from some
threshold that you know affects the
grass affects an insect uh you know
whatever right whatever it's calibrated
to right it really needs calibration it
does and you know I think you know if
you've heard any of my my extension and
talks or anything like that one of the
things I rant about is really using the
calendar to make these decisions that
are that are weather related right we've
we've done that for for a long time you
know whether it's uh you know when we
chat with you it's like oh it's the you
know I'm gonna get the date wrong the
first you know the first week in May we
need to put down uh dandelion control or
something like that but in in some years
that might be prudent in other years it
might not be so so the weather is a key
there
um I think really going back to your
first question it's really that pause
and I think again climate change factors
into that you know we could be looking
at a period of time say in January where
we do you know over a week or two do
accumulate a substantial amount
particularly of Base 32 Degree Days but
then you know it it we we plunge into
the deep freeze you know the polar
vortex comes over us in the rest of
March and all of February are you know
pretty much we're not collecting
anything so you know my my question
there becomes maybe I'm going to throw
it back to you what would you say in
your biology class does the turf respond
to that kind of jolt in in uh in January
and you know when it when it comes out
of that deep freeze being covered in
snow does does it remember that thank
you for asking it because my answer
would be I think it would be set back
further if in fact those plants and it
some of it is not understood honestly
because it's probably a function of
light
um you know the ground sat bear when it
was warm the sun beat down we were
seeing soil temperatures are at two
inches into the mid 50s brother on Long
Island right so yeah my feeling is those
plants respond to that temperature I
don't know that we know about the
potential light impact because you still
are fairly shallow angle that you know
mid late February so so that the first
thing is I don't know but my concern is
we get going then this stuff comes and
it's sets it back further and if I was
to say anything I would not pick up I'd
say let's just start doing it where it
accumulates consistently for two to
three weeks and then we're back in
business you you hit the key word there
right that's where I was going to end up
it's that consistent I think that
consistency needs to be a part of it
right if you're going through January
and you have a day here and a day there
or even into February March and you have
a day here that's very different than
this prolonged period of time where
where you know the biology of the turf
or whatever can kind of pick up and do
it I think in a lot of cases you know
the the fruit guys are maybe a little
bit more sophisticated with you right
because there they have a they have a
distinct measure on you know right you
have this idea of chilling right the
buds in an apple tree have to get a
certain amount of chill and that's when
you start to accumulate the degree days
it says all right we've gone through the
winter we've done our stuff we've gotten
enough of this and now I can start to
wake up but there doesn't seem to be
that that in in in the case of of turf
or or even insects and and things like
that so one of the things we've been
talking about uh we have for the last
couple of years and there's there's been
some research going on in
um Minnesota particularly on this uh the
concept of a false Spring right that
concept of fall spring can you just take
a minute and describe I mean this is a
is this a relatively new phenomenon as
part of the a signal of climate change
or is have the Springs always been
screwed up like this
um I don't know if they've always been
screwed up on that it's more
um
it's more um it's become more prevalent
in in a changing climate I mean I can go
way back right back in my South Dakota
days we did some work actually with with
tree rings so long records and that was
one of the things you looked at in the
trees this idea of false Springs you
could get these very very short small
Rings where the trees start to start to
go crazy in the spring and then it gets
really cold and you know we all know we
count the number of rings to see how old
the tree is right um but in those cases
there's like two rings there's that
false ring because the spring started so
this has been a phenomena that has gone
on you know for a long time right we're
looking at Thousand Year records in some
of these trees
um I I do think it becomes more
prevalent
um as as as we move on again we did some
work with
um we did some work with frost risk and
apples Frost damage and apples and and
the key thing that we see it's the
variation in the temperature right we
can warm up as much as we get and
there's really not this idea of fall
spring but as the as the variance the
day-to-day change becomes different
that's the thing that gives you that
that false spring that you know again in
the case of an apple blossom they
develop and then boom you get hit with a
frost and and it's down you know there
it's a one day thing in in what we're
talking about here I would say with Turf
we need a more prolonged period of time
of of it being cooler and having a fall
spring okay so Carl are there questions
yeah and there's a great question from
Jason Griffiths that goes right along
with this so he said he got some uh some
significant Growing Degree days in
mid-February but the soil Temps at two
inch two inches were still down at 31
degrees yeah he's asking how much is
that a key to keep the plan in dormancy
which for Turf is good right we don't
want it to acclimate 100 early because
then it's going to be more susceptible
to Winter kill what would you say to
that right yeah you first start I in
some ways I think that's the easy thing
to look at here right I mean we're
looking we're doing air temperature
we're not doing soil temperature so a
good case you could accumulate Degree
Days in in February but there's a foot
of snow on the ground right so that's
the easy thing to say hey these don't
count
um starting to look at the soil
temperature and if the soils are Frozen
um we we do get some data on that so
that might be another way of kind of
tempering what goes on in the spring
so art when you said you know the
simplistic Growing Degree day
calculations
um uh
how much of a difference you think there
is between doing it daily hourly Am Pm
we had an entomologist on Ben McGraw
from Penn State who pays attention to
this a little bit he he drew some
attention to the differences the way
they're calculated can you take a minute
I mean I think number one ours on our
websites are daily right daily right but
what about the differences in measuring
the more uh granularly well I mean I I
have two things there they're totally
going to be different right I mean you
have you know you you can think of a
specialty spring days if we're using
base you know base 50 or let's you know
as a degree day you have many days in
the in the mid to late spring where the
the daytime temperatures above 50 but
it's still below freezing at night right
so if you average that out then you get
zero degree days even though a good
chunk of the day what was in the 50s and
presumably that the plants were
responding to that however so yeah there
you do get a significant difference I I
think the numbers we look at about maybe
10 percent per particularly if you do it
hourly versus daily however however it
really doesn't matter that it depends on
what the models were built at so if
somebody built the model all on daily
values right that's that's right that's
that's what you're using in the model so
if you're saying this disease this
insects this whatever is going to occur
at this many Degree Days what's really
important to go back to literature and
say hey how did they compute okay so in
fact my question was good
a degree day is not a degree day when
there's a foot of snow on the ground and
to Jason's Point well done a degree day
is not a degree day if the soil is at 30
degrees and Frozen so I think it's
probably worth uh in places like that uh
really paying attention to it but at the
same time you know as you get further
south art right they have you know it's
it's it seems to be progressing in the
metropolitan areas in the urban areas
can you take one more second with our
Urban environmental scientist here and
talk about how this warming potentially
impacts grass areas around cities more
than it might uh in rural areas yeah I
mean I think this is a good winter to
actually just go out and look at that
I'm sure if you walk around New York
City or actually even on campus here if
you've been past Roberts Hall
um the witch hazel is already in bloom
it's it's bright yellow basically right
and same thing we did some more we did
some new stuff in the city where the
trees are are actually In Bloom and you
know that that City environment just
adds so much to the temperature it kind
of tempers those fluctuations that we
talk about so um in those types of
environments yeah it's it's key actually
because the mass heats up right all that
paved Mass right yep and it's it's like
a big old heat it's like a big old heat
sink right it's like you know sitting
around the campfire and the rocks are
still hot in the morning basically
that's right all right art well there we
go the
30 minutes Carl we defied the space-time
Continuum thanks for coming art we turn
right through it yeah thanks a town art
uh thank you always always a pleasure
Carl and Frank yep it's uh thanks thanks
everyone for joining today uh we'll be
back right again tomorrow with our
Sports show uh one of our attendees
today Ben polymer is going to be on
tomorrow we're going to quiz band on
some spring some of the spring
maintenance practices he does and a new
uh New England Regional BMP document for
the Sportster looking forward to it good
conversation thanks everyone we'll see
you tomorrow thanks Carl see art
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu